[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy the College of the Holy Cross in
Worcester Massachusetts is dropping its
Crusader mascot the college fix reports
that this ostensibly Catholic College
has decided to stop using Knight imagery
to represent its Crusaders nickname amid
concerns that it evokes the violence of
the Crusades and promotes Islamophobia
the Holy Cross Board of Trustees
declared that the Crusades were among
the darkest periods in church history
but the college is going to continue
using the crusader name while dropping
the knight mascot the board exhorted
students to instead see themselves as
Crusaders for leftist buzzwords saying
Crusaders for human rights social
justice and care for the environment for
respect for different perspectives
cultures traditions and identities and
for service in the world especially the
undeserved
and vulnerable holy cross president
father Philip Burroughs explained the
visual depiction of a knight in
conjunction with the moniker Crusader
inevitably ties us directly to the
reality of the religious wars and the
violence of the Crusades the lesson is
clear at Holy Cross the Crusades are
something to be ashamed of and the
school's Catholic students should not
take pride in knowing that the Crusades
are part of their church's history yet
as I show in my forthcoming book the
history of Jihad from Mohammed to Isis
the Crusades were not as holy cross
administrators and students evidently
assumed an unprovoked exercise of
protocol oniel ISM directed against a
peaceful Muslim world the Crusades were
in reality a late small-scale defensive
response after four hundred and fifty
years of jihad attacks had conquered and
aslam aside what had previously been
over half of the Christian world armies
animated by the jihad ideology or that
eventually justified their actions by
recourse to it had occupied much of the
Middle East North Africa Spain as well
as Persia and much of India centuries
before a Crusade was ever contemplated
they had entered France they had
besieged
Stanton Opel the capital of the
Christian Eastern Roman or Byzantine
Empire several times the Seljuk Turks
victory over the Byzantines at Men's
occurred in 1071 when they took the
Emperor Romano's the fourth Diogenes
prisoner open all of Asia Minor to them
in 1076 they conquered Syria in 1077 the
jihadis entered Jerusalem the Selya Emir
Otzi's bin wach promised not to harm the
inhabitants of Jerusalem but once his
men had entered the city they murdered
3,000 people that same year the Seljuks
established the Sultanate of Rome that
is Rome if it referring to the new Rome
Constantinople in Nicaea which was
perilously close to Constantinople
itself from there they continued to
threaten the Byzantines and harass the
Christians all over their new domains
the Byzantine Empire which before
Islam's wars of conquest had ruled over
a vast expanse including southern Italy
North Africa the Middle East and Arabia
was reduced to little more than Greece
they looked as if its demise at the
hands of the seljuqs was imminent the
Church of Constantinople considered the
Pope as somatic and had squabbled with
him for centuries but the new Byzantine
Emperor Alexei is the first Comnenus
swallowed his pride and appealed for
help and that is how the First Crusade
came about it was a response to the
Byzantine emperors call for help against
Muslim invaders who threatened to
destroy the Christian Empire it is
undeniable that the Crusaders committed
many atrocities
so did their jihadi opponents but in the
main the Crusader endeavor was not an
exercise in imperialism or colonialism
but an attempt to protect Christians
from Jihad attacks so why shouldn't Holy
Cross College have a Crusader mascot and
take pride in its own culture heritage
and history because that culture is
spent today in weak and confused and
anxious to appease a much more confident
alternative culture that regards the
Crusades as an affront the West
continues its cultural self-abnegation
in the face of the chimera of
Islamophobia which is of course a
propaganda neologism designed to make
people ashamed of defending themselves
and their homeland against a newly
aggressive Islamic Jihad Holy Cross of
course is not alone
the rush to disavow any connection to
Crusaders is part of a larger tendency
to remain in denial about the jihad
aggression that threatened so many
people in the world today it manifests
an acceptance of the Islamic view of
history which has been aggressively
thrust upon the West in recent decades
that blames the origin of conflict
between Muslims and Christians upon the
evil Crusaders
despite the timeline which proves this
false at a time when the Crusaders
ancient jihadi foes are newly
invigorated and more aggressive than
they have been for centuries this
cultural self-hatred is a recipe for
disaster
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]